it's a Saturday for me in Los Angeles
and because I am a total space nerd I've
come to North Hollywood to Norton sales
this place is legendary in the Aerospace
industry for decades they've been
hoarding any sort of space junk they
could
[Music]
get no less than a young pup of an Elon
Musk and a equally puppy Peter backck
from Rock lab came here before they
started their giant space
companies can look around find a valve
many valves a turbo pump whatever you
[Music]
need if you see the Mandalorian Star
Trek Star Wars pretty good chance they
picked up a few objects for this place 3
1 we have
a minutes the
to
follow if you too want to get space junk
you should come and if nothing else you
can sit in the
[Music]
Pod Los Angeles's Aerospace history goes
back a 100
years
some of the first plane companies were
here some of the first rocket
experimenters
too La helped turn the us into an
aerospace
superpower the Old Guard is still
here but now there's Elon musk's SpaceX
and a half dozen more rocket startups
not to mention Myriad more new satellite
and space manufacturing companies
SpaceX has turned into the Towering
giant of commercial space and many of
its spawn have turned La into the center
of the commercial space
Revolution as luck would have it I know
just the man to explain how this
happened and where this is all heading
if you are a nerd like me La can be a
magical place you can be by an oil
refinery and then a space startup at the
same time I'm here to meet Tom Mueller
he's the CEO of a startup called impulse
space he's the dude who built the first
engines for SpaceX he's a Gearhead he's
my kind of people and uh I think you all
should come meet
[Music]
Tom this is the the engine that I
designed actually before we even
Incorporated uh like this was just
floating around in your just around I
don't know it just snowballed and became
a company here we go often running can
we check out this guy
yeah my relationship with Tom goes
something like
this he makes cool space Hardware then
tries to explain it to me well I nod and
smile if you if you burn past that you
have what what are called cosine losses
okay so you just do a whole bunch of
short burns like when you're doing the
home and transfers like you have a huge
like say you're say you're going from
Leo you and you got to do
like well that's going to take like you
know the man has a beautiful mind going
to break and after 18 years sweating it
out under Elon he started his own space
company impulse I will show you its
wonders in a
minute but first Tom offered to drive me
around town in one of his many fast
cars oh yeah
[Music]
yeah in addition to being a rocket God
he's an amateur
racer
yes how many tickets have you gotten in
La I haven't had any late but i' I've
got quite a
few so the racing you just jumped into
it and you just yeah it's pretty
addicting it's uh you wouldn't be doing
it unless it was fun because it's crazy
expensive he may spend his Spare Time
Racing Porsches
now but Tom comes from humble
roots you're a you're an Idaho man
originally yep born and raised me and my
brothers were pretty wild riding bikes
hiking going out in the woods and
playing all the
time
when did it become obvious to you that
you were going to build rocket engines I
forget where I saw it of course but like
you know on some magazine or something
you fill out a form and you order these
SS rockets and wait you know weeks for
it to come like the model rockets yeah
little model rockets yeah little kits
and I build a lot of those and then I
got into high school and took a math
class and my math teacher said well Tom
you're really good at math you're going
to be an engineer right I go no I'm
going to be an aircraft mechanic he like
do you want to be the guy that fixes the
plane or the guy that designs the plane
that totally changed my
[Music]
life what did you first move to LA uh
1985 the Aerospace industry has had so
many ups and downs when you arrived was
it like a boom cycle it was a boom it
was a Reagan Era Star Wars and all that
was going going on this was the good
times yeah
yeah Tom worked for the next decade and
a half at companies like Hughes aircraft
and
TRW but then La space scene and the
space scene in general hit a Major Funk
Innovation stalled government and
Military bureaucracy reigned
[Music]
Supreme and then out of nowhere
the PayPal guy turned up in LA and
started talking about his dream to build
a colony on the red planet I don't think
we should be going back to the Moon I
think we should be focused on Mars half
the people well more than half would be
telling this guy Elon that that's crazy
but then there's there's going to be
this group of people that want to give
it a go right and you you end up as one
of those yep yeah I think there's a lot
of naysayers um I was not able to hire
very many people early on because they
just didn't think uh a small company
could do it right but but Elon you know
he he just has the spirit like we're
going to do it come H high
water all right now this is the building
right up here the first SpaceX building
yeah oh it is a fish place
now how long were you guys here was the
first one I think we moved in in about
June of 2002 so it was 5 years
the Machine Shop was straight back here
we built the first Falcon 9 first stage
in here and famously had to like remove
all the Landscaping to get it out yeah
so shouldn't this be like a historical
landmark or something yeah it's funny
that it's like a fish market
[Music]
or traditional Aerospace folks thought
of SpaceX is a complete joke and the
company had plenty of struggles during
its first
years still Tom and the rest of the
SpaceX team kept at
[Music]
it they built their engines named Merlin
and Kestrel and California and then
commuted to Texas to test
them sometimes they
worked sometimes they
didn't in 2008 all the hard work paid
off in spectacular fashion X made it to
orbit with a liquid fueled rocket a
first for a private rocket company Elon
always knew that we're going to be super
successful like he always said some our
name's going to be like as big as
boeings and I'm like yeah yeah all right
holy he was
right Tom didn't make much money at
SpaceX but his pride and his
accomplishments keeps him warm at night
stop it hit the middle button and then
you hit it and it'll go the other way
just kidding he's
loaded this is like when you know you've
made it when you've got a Ferrari
spinning around in here I'm blessed SPX
has been very good to
me are you worried that you have a
problem oh I definitely have a
problem then there's the Decked Out home
work shop where Tom can relive his Glory
Days flying hobbyist Rockets So this is
probably the smallest liquid rock had
ever flown 25 lbs of thrust inch and a
half in diameter it's kind of like a
cool part of Southern California though
is this whole thing where you can go
from LA to Mojave and just go do
whatever you want yeah two one
ignition looks like I'm might to salvage
the engine on this bab you know look
what came out of it you know because I
was known for making nice Parts when
Elon came and he knew some people in the
club he said hey I need an engine guy
they they recommended me and that's how
how that's how it happened
yeah all right we got to be careful this
is a construction zone out
here and of course the greatest man cave
of all
time so this is a the Merlin 1A so this
was the original flight engin that we
flew on the first two flights I know
every part of this thing i' I've machine
pendal tips for this thing and we live
this engine the room is filled with The
Spoils of Tom's four decade career in
space this right here is a is a limd uh
injector this is a lunar what they
landed on the moon when Armstrong was
throttling trying to find a place to
land he was throttling this engine Eagle
looking great here
go serious if you're anything like me
you could spend days here but there's no
time to hang around with relics of the
past next stop LA's Aerospace
future
[Music]
right when I started covering SpaceX it
was like the US Aerospace industry is
really sad and depressing and young
people didn't want to work there and
then you guys were at it for now these
like 20 years but now there's no more
exciting country anywhere if not only do
we have SpaceX but we've got small
rocket makers we've got tons of
satellites everything just the the
flywheel effect of SpaceX has started
the space really the this is the modern
era AG started right
there now that companies like SpaceX
have made getting off Planet relatively
affordable space Ventures are popping up
all over
La cooking up wild ideas to try out in
orbit like vaa Space Industries run by
William here a space
XX they set up shop a couple of years
ago in this former Skateboard Warehouse
vaa is the first in space B
manufacturing and Earth re-entry company
so what we do is we take advantage of
microgravity to make Unique Products
since it's a unique environment and then
we sell those products back on Earth
people have talked about this for years
but you're you're really the first that
are going to try to do Manufacturing in
space yeah exactly so it's not my idea
or uh it's been around for decades uh
people have just been waiting for launch
costs to drop low enough to make this
economically
feasible V's first space Manufacturing
project will be essentially
molecules it's been shown that novel
atomic structures can be formed in
microgravity the hope is that more
useful things will result like new
life-saving medicines the pharmaceutical
industry just thinks of us as a
bioreactor and then when they they walk
away we just take it we put to space
real quick and then we bring it back and
that's equivalent to turning the gravity
Knob Off for that chamber while we run
that automated process you guys also
have plans for possibly like giant
factories that's more in like the 10 to
20 year time frame the first thing
you'll see is just rapid Cadence of
small launch vehicles to take advantage
of microgravity the bet that we're
making as a company is that
manufacturing comes before tourism uh
and and as the next step of
commercialization of the cosmos for now
varda's molecular magic will take place
in this small capsule that they call the
bird
bath so this one has served its purpose
it's been on a parachute drop test uh
quite a few times this is kind of the uh
dilapitated uh uh test
[Music]
vehicle inside the capsule is where the
weightless chemistry happens I would
love to show you what that looks like
but we can't do the payload yeah so
that's
secret which means it's time for our
recurring
segment a child draws the proprietary
technology
can you describe it in as much detail
and we will create an artist
representation hi my name is ran sha I'm
going to draw some pictures for you
today so we're taking two fluids mixing
them together and then putting them
through a temperature profile it is just
that oh good question okay so what I
mean by that is just changing the
temperature as a function of time so you
know first we put the crock pot on high
to get everything warm and then you put
it on low and you let it simmer for 8
hours I still don't understand the outer
part's aluminum okay and then the inner
parts two vessels with the main sources
of liquid dis solvent the antisolvent
they get mixed through a series of tubes
and a series of growth Chambers for the
molecules that we want to formulate and
then we put them through a temperature
profile as to to stimulate that
formulation all done and there you have
it
space drugs are cool
obviously but space has more to give so
much more and some of those flying rocks
above us are worth a whole lot of Earth
[Music]
money which part of the adventure are we
at which part of the adventure uh Jose
is the CTO of astrof Forge which is
engaged in the getrich slow scheme of
asteroid mining
he too used to work at the bird bands
Intergalactic phus company before moving
into space prospecting along with CEO
Matt asteroid mining I mean it's it's
like fairly simple conceptually I guess
these asteroids well we know right they
contain just just huge quantities of of
minerals and elements and the the quest
is just to go get them yeah so we're
specifically targeting what are called
the metallic group asteroids or mtype
asteroids right we know that they have a
much higher percentage of Platinum Group
group metals on them right these six
elements that are a ton of industrial
use cases that you may have seen or been
used for I mean your iPhone itself
contains all of these Metals inside it
to make it operate and work and we're
running out of them on Earth you can't
just go make these right we have to find
a new source we have to find a new
expans that we can go grab them
from Astro Forge is not quite ready to
send Bruce Willis in Ben Affleck to an
asteroid but they are busy developing
all the tools for the job the office is
littered with experiments in vaporizing
space rocks and detecting the valuable
minerals
inside on the day we visited the team
was preparing for its first stab into
the void this will be the first in space
Refinery to fly so we take an asteroid
like sample up uh it's already loaded
okay we vaporize that sample and we we
keep what's what's valuable to us which
is the Platinum so you tested all this
stuff here on Earth and then now this is
a chance go into orbit and see if things
work as expected and then later this
afternoon yes this goes towards a SpaceX
rocket that's right we're going to go
drive this thing up to Vandenburg and
it's going to get uh integrated onto uh
the deployer and then that'll get
integrated onto the Falcon
9 if all goes well Astro for James to
visit an asteroid for the first time
later this decade and bring back more
than 2,000 lb of platinum it might all
sound a bit Fantastical but for Jose
it's the next logical step for a space
industry he helped build I got into
asteroid mining because I love
exploration and deep space SpaceX was a
way for me to enable that for others um
I just didn't realize that I was going
to enable it for myself right open up
all this possibility so like in the past
if you wanted to do an asteroid mining
Mission I mean you probably you would
probably have to buy entire rocket which
you're lucky if it cost 300 million yeah
absolutely and you guys are going to pay
say less than 5 6 million some for a
very high energy launch to get out and
so we don't have to carry as much
propellant um we don't have to build a
bigger vehicle like this is this is
[Music]
gamechanging people love this
car from his Carefree Manner and the
fact that he has time to drive me around
La it might be obvious that Tom no
longer works for
Elon he started a space company of his
own what stage are you at we're we're
fully in it and we're we're raising our
series a right now so it's getting
pretty intense I hear all the founder
story and how hard it is to get money
it's pretty easy for us it's got to be
okay for Tom Mueller
yeah can't complain we're doing all
right we'll we'll do fine
[Music]
now impulse makes space engines which as
the name implies move things around in
space cheap rocket flights have led to a
surge in the number of satellites and
those satellites often need thrusters to
maneuver into the correct position
impulse wants to make those thrusters
powerful and efficient enough to help
Humanity conquer the vacuum the future
you're laying out is one where there's
lots of stuff up there it's moving
around things are getting refueled this
thing's going over there for this job if
you watch your sci-fi shows any of them
they're moving right they're not just
sitting in one place hanging out we're
all about um movement in space we're a
space logistics
company it's an undertaking that
naturally starts in Tom's home Workshop
it's going be 5-second delay and then
it's going to be a 5-sec burn okay
everybody ready on five five 5 4 3 2
1 super cool man that'll
like yes this is a real prototype space
engine which Tom designed and built all
by himself in his
garage
you don't miss doing the big giant stuff
20 years at SpaceX I got my fill of the
booster engines yeah and now the next
thing is in space yeah like we want to
do like lunar Landers and we got the
Mars program like it's it's just super
cool when he's done tinkering with his
designs Tom brings them to the impulse
team so they can be put through their
paces and developed into space where
they products how long have a burn I
have 180 seconds go longer if you want
no that's
fine this chamber simulates the vacuum
of space where the engine will
eventually do its
thing elsewhere in the office you can
find craft designed to visit other
planets we got to sack up and land on
Mars so this is a Mars Lander
development vehicle we call it the
hopper that we're going to take out to
the desert and do hop tests with it yeah
so governments space agencies have been
to Mars but no commercial entity has
ever landed anything will'll be the
first you guys are ambitious right it's
2024 for this is the goal 26
okay this was like my early design here
Tom thinks big and he has Skyhigh
aspirations for the new space economy I
really want to see like manufacturing
space like what vard is doing and I
think at some point they're going to
start thinking like why are we lifting
all of our raw materials from the
gravity well of Earth up when it's
literally like 22 times easier to bring
it from the surface of the
Moon as if Moon mining wasn't enough how
about putting all of Earth's server
farms in orbit the amount of power to
run compute by like 2045 will be like
the base power of the planet right now
the drain on resources is so high you
need to put that compute in space and
just use the power of the Sun in space
making the the the solar cells in space
and do Computing in space and just beam
the results down so I think that's like
a really good use of space to help save
the
Planet 3 2 1
[Music]
zero if any of those wild ideas come to
pass it'll be thanks in no small part to
Tom and his game-changing rocket engines
at the very least he's made a massive
contribution to the weird and wonderful
new Industries taking shape in
space and one day Tom hopes to go there
himself so you grew up as a kid being
interested in this you ended up working
on a company that's sending people to
space all the time now is that something
you've ever wanted to do absolutely yeah
I assume you're not like the six minute
edge of space kind of guy I would
imagine you want a couple laps around
the moon or something like that I want
to land on the moon you want to land on
I would really it's like my B bucket
list item would be to ride an electric
dirt bike on the
moon like jump some craters you know I
feel like that is what should happen for
Tom mu it it should absolutely
[Music]
happen